are you ready
welcome to the harlem culture festival
here in the haunted house what time is
it
you will not be able to stay home
brother
[Music]
you will not be able to plug in turn on
and cop out
you will not be able to lose yourself on
stag and skip out for fear during
commercials because
the revolution will not be televised
[Applause]
the revolution will not be told would
that be televised
revolution will be live
[Music]
this is the first theater i've been in
since coviz
yeah was that y'all's first time in a
theater
it's like a crazy thing to come back to
it's so immersive
you know clearly this is a a lightning
and a bottle moment for me so you can't
plan phenomenons it's not like that you
know
michael jackson can say okay if i
release this album thriller on november
30th 1982
the synergy of this new platform called
mtv's
we're gonna write each other that glory
like you can't no matter how many times
he wants to sell like
200 million copies like you can't plan
by eating in a bottle so
um did i know
um back in 2017
that you know all that was ahead of us
to get to this point no absolutely not
so um but
i think the intent was to do
um kind of an immersive
and educational music experience that
um that's engaging
and um that plays well
in theaters yeah yeah now it feels
really theatrical to me i saw it once on
hulu and then i saw it here
and the moment when martin luther king
gets shot
it's like that it is so
visceral i gotta tell you
that probably um
i spent more time for starters
[Music]
the editing process a lot of this
was done and approved like on laptops
uh my iphone oh my god do you move this
cut
you know so wait your system okay
now the sound guy means that can we turn
the mids down
[Music]
sorry
um yeah and so uh
the first day i got to watch i purposely
didn't want to watch uh any of our cuts
in any theater setting even as we were
like approving sound and whatnot
[Music]
but i knew that particular pow scene
we worked so hard i said i wanted to be
jolting because the thing was is that
um there are a few moments in which
the interview subjects were just like
small talking me
as we were waiting to roll i i wasn't
aware that we were rolling already like
the the situation with musa jackson at
the end the whole
i know you're not crazy like we yell cut
already so he and i were just like
casually talking so i didn't even know
that we caught that
and the same with um jesse jackson
um normally you know in the interview
process you're supposed to
you know do the pre-interview and
everything okay okay so you already know
the questions i'm gonna ask you but i
didn't have that process with jesse so
i just said hey i'm going to ask you a
few questions about you know
benjamin branch and and his role martin
luther king's like yadda yadda
and um he instantly started telling the
story and the thing was i
i had to uh we
my first draft was like three hours and
20 minutes amateur hashtag amateur
no rough cut right right so it was like
three hours and 20 minutes
and so um
the way that jesse jackson talked about
the last 10 minutes
of martin luther king's life
um was jaw-dropping to me and simply
because like i grew up this whole time
thinking about like
april 3rd of 68 where he does the
mountaintop speech where he gives the
speech about like
will you sort of get this omen that like
oh he knows that he's not going to make
it and
you know he actually predicted like i'm
not going to get there with you and of
course he's necessity so there's
i've always grew up with this sort of
gloomy
last 24 hours i know i'm going to die
any moment
sort of idea of what martin luther king
was and the story that jesse jackson
told
um was the complete opposite like in
almost the way that he told it the only
way i can
sort of describe it in a sustained way
which is the opposite of this answer i'm
giving you right now
um it's almost like the
the benny hill yakity saks theme could
have played
and how he described the last 10 minutes
because
for those last 10 minutes they were
having a pillow fight
i tried to keep like in in the beginning
you hear like
he says like you know we're just trying
to relax and whatever you know
throwing around pillows but he went into
detail about
the fact that jesse was sort of like
complaining to king about like
oh man like we're just getting dinner do
we have to wear a suit
like can't we just wear a casual clothes
to this woman's house like we know this
woman like we don't have to get dressed
up
it's not sunday and um
and the room was silent and then like
abernathy threw a pillow at jesse and
jesse threw her pillow at
andrew young and young and then king so
they were having a
knock down drag out pillow fight and
then they started ranking on each other
talking about each other's moms like
playing with dozens
like joking on each other and
then of course you know benjamin branch
came and then
history was forever altered but yeah
that's one of the many discoveries
of that night so when he told me the
story i
jumped i wasn't ready for that right and
we were just casually talking to each
other
like this yeah and i just remembered
uh telling um josh pearson like man
like i want the audience to jump the
same way i did when he said pal
like i was so engaged in the story so
when i seen it for the first time
in theaters uh in harlem on
june 19th they didn't realize why but
like i was in the front row and then
suddenly they're like
wait why is the mirror like turning
around watching us and i stuck my camera
out
it was like a horror film like literally
they all jumped and then like
all collectively looked at me like you
did this like so
um yeah that's that that one moment
really got me
yeah well i i i um purposely did not
read the answer to this next question
because i sort of
want i don't know how many people know
this but um
like how did you find this footage i
imagine it's something like a bunch of
musicians on a tour bus late at night
like talking about the lore of some
magical missing footage was it like that
or is there a different story
all right so i i come from um
i come from a world a very small world
of like
even before the term like uh humble brag
you know got invented on social media
um you know there's a there's a small
circle
of us in the hip-hop world who
will leave no stone unturned to collect
artifacts like if you think of like the
the figurine star wars collection and
the 40 year old virgin
like there's kind of that in the hip-hop
world with like
me like really the person who started
all which makes it really sad
now is is bizmarquee like he's the first
person that we saw that like
collected these albums from other
countries and you know found this
lunchbox collection in detroit and went
thrifting and found you know and
so having been uh
going to tokyo for the first time where
at that moment
what year what year this is 1997. okay
first time that the roots are in tokyo
and um
my translator uh said like wow
you're you're afro i could i feel like
you're you're a fan of the 70s show
soul train which clearly i was
and she says that i want to take you to
this uh soul train cafe
i was like there's the soul train themed
cafe in tokyo
and uh it's basically fridays
with monitors on the screen anywhere
that's what
that's kind of what it is and um you
know there's a bunch of uh
monitors on the wall what not so i had
unknowingly
saw uh maybe two minutes of the slide in
the family stone clip
but it was a it was like a far away
camera so i couldn't see the faces that
were watching sliding the family stone
so because of what i thought i knew
about the music business i just
naturally thought that oh
festival culture really wasn't a thing
in the united
states until like lollapalooza's like
we're just starting now
in the first 20 years of festival
culture but i just thought it was like
mantra jazz festival or maybe like i
know that niece does an
outdoor show so that's what i thought it
was so then cut to 20 years later
um backstage at the tonight show um
at the time my assistant had told me
that these two gentlemen want to talk to
me about
uh this festival in
uh you know harlem that allegedly at
stevie wonder
and slyly family stone whatever so the
first thing i do of course is call like
my source crew of like journalists that
nelson george and people but as a new
brand new new yorker i didn't realize
that brooklyn and harlem don't
mess with each other too much so i
happen to have a whole bunch of brooklyn
people like
yo man you ever heard this concert in 69
like this alleged black woodstock or
whatever and you know they were like
i never heard that i never heard that so
after like the knife music stop
then i i just settled in my head that
i'm a little skeptical this didn't
happen then i googled it and nothing was
there
on google oh my god literally nothing
was like all that you see now the harlem
cultural festival is like
post wow announcements so then they
found like artifacts and whatnot but
back in 2017 there was none of that so i
was
really really skeptical to the point
where i just thought like
maybe these two just wanted tonight show
tickets
like finesse their way into that sort of
thing but um
yeah david dennison and robert feilin um
had the footage and then what was it
like to watch
everything stopped because then i became
instantly
defensive like wait why why me why are
you doing this to me it's
it's it's you know i i can't
describe the you know it's just like
well let me
just let me be the producer or something
i'll be the face of it
and um they were like no you're
you're a storyteller like you do this
natural you don't even know it
at the time i was teaching at nyu
uh i was on my fourth book then i had a
podcast
and they were like you yourself and your
book said that you know uh
talent is and creativity is transferable
so you could just
you know do this and
um in the beginning there was you know
trepidation
like can i really do this can i really
do this but i mean once i dived in i
realized that
it's bigger than me like i think i was
more or less worried that i was given a
responsibility to
correct history so it's like i'm going
to the plate and this has to be a grand
slam
like there's no ground rule double or
you know getting walked the first place
like it has to be a grand slam so
artists and creatives are very neurotic
like that so
i got over it in three months and just
doving
yeah i just felt it and we're in it
wow so back to the story of of like
so you found the footage because these
two guys came backstage and then it's
just sort of
what well they um
they had 40 hours of footage so i was
like there's 40 hours of this
and i don't care like if
this is your passion in life or like if
you're indifferent
like 40 hours of anything that's a
that's a tedious
even if it's pleasurable it's a very
tedious thing so picking the right
moments
yeah like i just saw this you know i
tend to uh
whenever numbers are mentioned um i
don't care if it's doing exercise reps
or whatever like
i i see these giant fonts and just the
number 40 just seemed like very
overwhelming to me stevie wonder or not
i was just like 40 hours
so i didn't know the process of even
doing the research
and then um i took a
cue from prince prince
prince was world famous for his love of
pixar
more specifically his love for finding
nemo
is a long story just google google
google quest love prince finding nemo
you'll see a story of his obsession with
it so
you know at the time i asked him i'm
like why like
i don't know anyone that travels around
with like a pulp fiction briefcase
of like 10 finding nemo dvds like in
case you lose one i got nine more
and prince said that um with finding
nemo and also with uh another
uh film this criterion film called uh
black orpheus um it's something about
the
the colors that pop that he's like
to him uh finding nemo's like the the
world's best
aquarium so he always keeps it playing
like that's his
happy place or whatever like i have an
aquarium so i said well
prince style i'll just do this as an
aquarium so we made a
giant mpeg and
i put it on my hard drive and i have the
ability to control
or watch it on any monitor that i go to
either at work in the studio my bathroom
my kitchen
my living room my bedroom and i kept
this
constantly running like a jukebox never
turning off for like five months
wow so even if i was asleep that's how i
you know finally saw the uh the mavis
and uh mahalia thing like
for two in the morning i woke up like oh
okay write that down
and if there were 30 once i got to 30
things that i felt like
that's a goosebump mum not like oh
that's nice but something that really
like
was jarring then i said okay now we have
a foundation
to build upon so it took five months for
me to just
get that 30 moments that i felt were
strong and then we built from there
and then i was stuck with three and a
half three hours in 20 minutes
well i think like that's a really
interesting way to think about building
a cut because i do think it's like
there's so many goosebump moments in the
movie and there's a line i wrote down i
just wanted to ask you about kind of
connecting to the activism in the film i
i remember it was a goosebump moment for
me the first time but then watching it
here
going to war propelled on a wave of
music
that line yes can you talk about that
line
yeah it's it's to me um
it's it's the idea
um and i know in no well not even
hindsight just in general
i know that oftentimes um musicians
are faced with the task of
solving the world's problems or you know
when it's time to raise money for famine
then
who's more effective you're a politician
to solve the problem or a musician to
do that you know or protest music or
whatever
and i
feel that basically music is probably
the most common denominator neutralizer
for any situation that's music is a
language that we can all share
and so that's that's what i feel that it
means right
well i think you really i think you
really um thread the needle like
as a director like just sort of
this is a such a joyous music film but
it's also very much an activist film
and was that just inherent in them i
mean obviously
yeah so tel talk a long journey to this
okay cool cool
um just in general um
you know for those that aren't super
familiar with my
other 17 jobs um the quickest way to
really describe
what the roots are who the roots were
when we started
out of high school like in 1992
we kind of took the if the grateful dead
oarfish or a hip-hop band
that's the route we took and we lived on
a tour bus
for for 250 days off the year
from 92 all the way up right before the
tonight show like
2009 so 18 years of just living
on the road it was often my
responsibility
to provide our tour buses with
entertainment so i'm the guy that would
you know shell five thousand dollars up
at
amoeba's dvd section or you know
whatever the art house
spot is or just i mean that's at the
time when you could buy like
uh dvds and whatnot and so um
for me spending
14 15 hour stretches on a tour bus
there's only but so many ways that you
can watch
the godfather or whatever and then i
started delving deeper into
expanded editions and watching directors
commentaries
and all those so i've all and now it's
to the point where
i will watch the director's commentary
first before i even watch the actual
film
um so that's just naturally just how i'm
built like i'm more interested in the
the the mechanism
the engine more than i am the car or
even the destination i like the journey
um so in the beginning when we really
started which i'll say top of 2018.
maybe i was slightly intrigued with
sydney paulx's direction of aretha
franklin's
amazing grace documentary whereas just
the performance
and no context whatsoever now
you know as a stickler for information i
do know of the infamous like
argument between james cleveland and um
uh
drummer for the stones charlie watts
charlie watts had parked in james
cleveland spot and
crashed the back of his car or something
like that and so an argument ensued but
like i would have loved to know details
about that
you know or like clara walker sort of
walking in late
and sort of causing aretha franklin to
almost like
lose her those are the details i wanted
to know
but i thought it was smart that he never
took you out of the church and kept you
in the audience
so in the beginning i thought okay let
me just find
15 really great songs and curated the
white
right way um but because of the weather
inconsistency i thought it would be
weird trying to explain like well why
was it why was stevie wonder holding an
umbrella during
my sharia more but then it's like david
ruffin
is sweating in 106 degree weather in a
wool
tuxedo in the middle of august but then
it's real dark and it's raining on the
staple singers so the weather
inconsistency kind of messed that theory
up and then
[Music]
i'll say that around
mid 2018 i realized how
i was going to make this film relatable
to gen x
and i'm sorry uh gen z and millennials
which is the fact that they they happen
to be living
in the same conditions in the same
political situation
and the same social situation as 50
years ago
and so you know with people my age and
older of course it's like
you know glass nine the pips you know
these acts and either you lived and
lived through that time or me as a
person who grew up with samples and
knowing those acts because my parents
listened to them gen x and baby boomers
were covered
but with z and millennials
i felt the relatable experience was not
knowing the acts but just
knowing the time and then that's when
i really you know we
we made a decision to figure out how to
make it educational without it without
this action which i'm known for like you
know people roll their eyes like
here comes another one of his long
speeches again about
the microphone technique that lionel
richie used on that out of record or
whatever and so
um yeah and then just bit by bit
i'll say the first thing that made me
want to do it was uh
and looking at the uh stevie wonder
performance which is the exact moment
man lands on the moon um
okay well you guys saw the the easter
egg at the end
i'm so mad oh okay easter egg but you
don't have to explain it to them but
right well gene key
his uh musical director and stevie sort
of had this like uh
kind of uh
uh post-vaudeville uh
schtick going on where like gene key's
the bad guy and stevie's the good guy
it's like a comedy routine going on the
whole set and so there's a moment
right after that get your hand on my
pocket thing where
gene key ranks on stevie about like well
you know history is being made right now
man's on the moon and you're here
in harlem singing a song a love song
like and the audience starts booing
and you know i pause i'm like wait a
minute did they just boo the moon
landing like
did i miss something because i i went to
a school where that sort of thing was
celebrated and
here's your free glass of tang and you
know like everything that
that they taught us about like what the
moon represented and um
once we started looking under the hood
then it was like
do we have a responsibility to show like
what the thoughts really were and then
once that happened then it just became
a giant boulder of packing
information yeah i mean i'm
i i definitely feel that tension as a
filmmaker and like
explaining but i definitely am so glad
because
just hearing gladys knight talk about
her transformation and just
the audience too and like
and i really i really had to credit um
you know uh
my team josh pierce and my editor um
you know he's a musician
and that to me was important um joseph
patel
my uh the other producer of uh
of this film told me that we should
approach this almost like the way that
you approach your dj gigs
and you know i'm always trying to give
context and educate people like
this song game was you know derivative
of this song from 20 years ago and then
they did their verse
you know so i'm always trying to do that
in my dj kick so
we just applied the same thing like
rhythm there's a rhythm and a pace to it
all and
same way yeah i wondered if the editor
was a musician because it absolutely
feels like the editor is a musician that
he just
understands and also i'm a micro manager
like
there was a there's maybe there's two
times
in which naturally uh i caught audience
members clapping on the one and the
three
which which kind of irks me a little bit
so there's a few times where i cheated
like like no man you gotta you gotta
make it look like they're actually
dancing on rhythm and not like clapping
on the wrong part of the song so
but you know josh totally got where i
was going with it that's great yeah
um so what's it like like right now to
bring this like
incredible shared experience out into
the world
i you know um
i've had a lot of you know this
this has been a crazy you know near
30-year journey of my life
and nothing has ever prepared me for
this like this was
never on my bingo card of like
you know one day you might you know
i never thought that i'd be in the
position to do that but um
i'm just i'm absolutely overwhelmed i
think this is the first thing
um that i've created i like to think
that i'm an
artist in a niche lane which is sort of
like you know the roots are
kind of a cult group that like has a
very specific fan base and
um or there's people that will discover
after the fact of things that i've done
like you know like oh okay you're part
of the team that gave us hamilton and
you
you worked on this elvis costello record
and did it like
i'm used to doing things and then
hearing about it like three years later
like
oh man of course you were part of that i
didn't know you did that so
this this might be the first thing that
i've done
in which maybe besides the tonight show
which an absolute ripple instant ripple
effect
um in real time happens and
you know this is only the first week and
already
um yeah it's very
i mean overwhelming in a good way right
a welcome
overwhelming so cool um
okay um so as a musician
um did you like you know watching the
footage the first time is there like
a group or someone you identified with
the most
or a moment okay so i'll say that
the two moments that uh hit me the most
um again a candid conversation that we
just happened to catch
um and talking to billy davis and
maryland makuu
um i
because i was so familiar with
their work and their tv appearances when
i was young
i said well i said i noticed um i told
the billy davis junior i was like wow
i've never heard you
use your your gospel
baritone in any performance ever you
know
his and do me and all those like 60s
isms
i'd never seen that from the fifth
dimension ever because
when they're on jack parr's tonight show
when they're
on ed sullivan's show it's a very
prim improper sophisticated elegant
presentation and um
instantly this is the black people often
go through this
and the process is called code switching
where
you kind of have to uh camouflage and
blend into a situation and
instantly i recognize that like oh
okay so what was different i said this
is probably the most relaxed
free performance like i've never seen
you guys do the twist or the watusi or
any of those dances and
grab people from the audience and i said
i've never seen that ever and they were
just like
we were happy like we never performed in
front of this many black people
before ever you know because instantly
they were a pop group
they were at the copa it was like
mainstream acceptance and they rarely
they didn't have to go through the
chitlin circuit that every other
black hat had to go through and then
another telling moment
[Music]
was the david ruffin tuxedo situation
what made sly stone's performance so
revolutionary if you watch
camera 4 which is the audience camera
what made
that performance so revolutionary was
that was the first time
that black people got to see
black musicians on stage not have to
wear
uh suits you know because you were
taught
via motown charm school that again you
got to be non-threatening
wear a tuxedo prim and proper you know
nothing even james brown as
wild and down home as his performances
was
you know he would find you if there was
a scuff in your shoes
the one question i would always ask any
of his band members bootsy collins or
fred wesley or maceo parker was like you
guys did five shows a night
sweaty like who took care of your suits
like there was no
wardrobe person on duty so the thing was
is that i was amazed that
david ruffin in the name of
professionalism
would rather suffer in a wool tuxedo
in the middle of august outdoors i mean
i'm foolish for wearing a sweater it was
cold in my hotel room this morning so
i put a hoodie on and then came outside
like uh this is a bad idea
so just but the rule of law back then
was like
professionalism over your own comfort
and the fact that the biggest middle
finger
that sly could have given was the fact
that he came out in his street clothes
which was
never so for a lot of audience members
watching uh people under the age of 25
lose their collective minds because one
slot in the family stone wasn't even
announced
so it was like oh my god they're here
that sort of thing and that's why you
see the audiences their mind meanwhile
every parent
is like wait who are these aliens
that's what it was like so just to watch
the first three songs where the parents
were just like i don't know what this
is i've never seen a woman play trumpet
before they allowed it like
it was just new and then by song four
suddenly you see the shift and suddenly
the parents are losing their minds and
the kids are like okay you're going over
the top now like
that's they just won the audience over
so i loved seeing that
yeah oh it's so powerful um well i'm
being told we don't have any time and
i'm also not supposed to ask the
audience any questions but i bet you
guys have some right
yeah i'll gladly take some and i'll try
to keep my answers short
should we just yes
okay i'll be the moderator
the only person with your arm up go
ahead you get this
wait you gotta stand up cause i can't
see who's talking
okay hello
thank you
man i'm gonna tell you something
not even one percent not even i would
probably say we made
.04 adjustment we were so
gobsmacked with the roughnecks
that our final mix couldn't even compete
with it so what you were listening to
was just the reference mix and that's
one of the
next to the whereabouts of tony lawrence
which we couldn't find or his wardrobe
the the the number one question i had
um and this is coming from a guy who's
in a band
that uses 67 outlets
they only used 15 microphones
15. like stevie wonder said alone three
of those mics
are on stevie's drums that he only plays
once in that whole set
so three mics were stevie's drums three
mics for stevie's other drummer so
that's six
the bass and the guitar players sharing
one microphone between like two amps
that are facing each other
and then uh there's stevie's keyboard
stevie's vocal and then the remaining
four mics are on the entire brass
section
and it was clear and pristine and
i have no clue or ideal
how that happened and you know
like i jimmy douglas
uh is one of the best engineers from his
work with barry white
all the way to his work with missy and
timberland like he's my favorite
engineer ever and he did amazing grace
also
he just like i just added very little
next to no reverb just like an eighth of
it like the
rough mix was was what you were
listening to so
i'm amazed at the sound of it myself one
more question
stand up yeah okay um
been yes preserved and archived and
cataloged
is it was there any thought in your
creation of the film
to creating something larger i know that
a film in it
in and of itself
yeah i'll say that um
probably mid research i came back to the
team
um first i try to say well this is
really weird i was like guys i don't
know
maybe we should just do um
maybe we should do a short documentary
like let's tell
let's tell a 12 minute story
can you imagine that um yeah but i
seriously was just like uh
maybe we should just do a short
documentary like let's just do a very
succinct like uh 12-minute version
um yeah i'll say that and then i went
the opposite thing i was just like yo
there's too much information like why
don't we turn this into a series like
we'll sell it to
netflix and do a series on it
um but they were like no this this has
to be a movie
and we stuck to it probably the
biggest chunk that i had to take out
well to answer your question yes
um every bit of the film
that's why i had the five month window
to watch
um you know in the various times that
hal tulsian had
to sell or try to pitch the material
like he made transfer tapes and whatnot
over the last 20 years
so that's what i was watching on loop
however the original two-inch tapes
i've never those that was like one of
the first times that
because normally an event like this
would have been uh like 35 millimeter
film or
16 you know using video
tape was like a brand new thing for 69
it was seen as like
the new revolu you know new revolution
but you know
what i saw it was like oh this looks
like a soap opera or
you know like a nightly newscast like
that sort of film quality
um we found there
are i believe six people
in america that have the facility
and the know-how on how to bake treat
and process that film
and they said pretty much they had to go
frame by frame of
27 reels and these reels were like
somewhere between 12
and 17 pounds very heavy and you have to
be very careful with it so
it took them five months to lightly
brush
all the frames it was little to no
little to no damage like i'm very very
shocked because
any situation of like something's
sitting that long
and there have been times where they
tried to you know sell it whatever and
deals fell through but there's always
been damage like i know the princess
state
all the tapes that were on the bottom of
his
uh studio like 19 of those tapes got
destroyed once the team got in there to
archive
princess stuff but yes we've preserved
all those things so i assume that we
will do
more expanded uh versions so that people
can see the full performances
yeah thank you thank you
thank you guys for enjoying it thank you
you